ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY.
A I AND TO WE HAVE A VERY BUSY
AFTERNOON HERE IN THE CAPITAL SO
WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
QUIRK SILVA -- CAN YOU PLEASE
PRESENT -- AB THREE SIX EIGHT
MISTER OF VOEPEL SHOULD BE HERE
ANY MOMENT.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SIGN PLEASED TO BE HERE --
THIS BILL HAS BEEN A BILL THAT
HAS MOVED THROUGH THE STATE
LEGISLATURE MORE THAN. TWO TIMES
AND WE ARE BACK FOR OUR THIRD
TIME AND THIS BILL IS A BILL
THAT WE HAVE PERSISTED ON AS WE
BELIEVE.
DEEPLY AND PROFOUNDLY THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- NEEDS A
PLACE FOR OUR VETERANS WHO HAVE
SERVED AS A FINAL RESTING PLACE
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND THAT WOULD
SERVE ALL OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ON MARCH FOURTH ELEVENTH TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE IRVINE CITY COUNCIL
BY UNANIMOUS VOTE DESIGNATED AND
AMENDED AND RESTATED AT RESTATED
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENT FOR AN
ARTIST SITE AT THE GREAT PART.
AS THE BEST POSSIBLE SITE FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
MEMORIAL PARK IN CEMETERY.
SO IF YOU NOTED THAT WAS MARCH
ELEVENTH TWENTY FOURTEENTH AND
WE ARE NOW IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN HISTORY
DEMONSTRATES THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORTS A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS MEMORIAL
PARK IN CEMETERY.
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION SELECTED
THE ARTISTS SITE AND ALLOCATED
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION TO A
MASTER DEVELOPMENT FUND.
THIS MEASURE RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
LATER IN EL ALTERNATIVE SITE WAS
OFFERED IN MANY OF US IN THIS
ROOM VOTED TO FUND THE CAL THAT.
ENVY A REQUIRED STUDY AND SEED
MONEY FOR THIS ALTERNATE SITE NO
NO ONE AS THE STRAWBERRY.
SITE UNFORTUNATELY A LOCAL
REFERENDUM WAS SUCCESSFULLY PASS
THAT REMOVES THE AUTHORIZATION
TO TRANSFER THE LAND TO THE
STATE AND PLACED US BACK AT THE
ORIGINAL SITE.
ALL HAVE PROCLAIM THEIR SUPPORT
FOR A VETERANS CEMETERY YEP
PARTIES HAVE YET TO IDENTIFY ONE
SITE THAT DEVELOPS.
THE NECESSARY CONSENSUS.
SOMETIMES.
IT BECOMES NECESSARY TO PRESS
FORWARD AND MOVE FORWARD -- AS
FRUSTRATED STAKEHOLDERS TO GET
BACK TO THE TABLE TO DEVELOP
THAT CONSENSUS IT IS MY FERVENT
HOPE THAT THIS BILL WILL DO THAT
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE IS MISTER RICHARD
VALDEZ.
WHO IS THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA DISABLED VETERANS?
THANK YOU CHAIR.
BOB WORK WE'VE BEEN IN SUPPORT
OF THIS SITE CEMETERY FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING WHEN THE FIRST
BILL -- CAME OUT AND WAS PASSED
I TESTIFIED BEFORE THE IRVINE
NOT CITY COUNCIL IN FAVOR THE
BILL AND THROUGH THROUGH THESE
YEARS WE'VE CONTINUED TO PROFESS
THAT.
A CEMETERY IN IRVINE AND OR
ORANGE COUNTY IS IS NECESSARY
OUR VETERANS AND IN THAT REGION
AND PART OF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AS WELL.
I HAVE TO MAKE THEIR WAY TO
RIVERSIDE AND IF YOU'VE EVER
DRIVEN DOWN THE NINETY ONE
FREEWAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT A TASK THAT IS AND
AS FAMILIES AGE THAT BECOMES
THAT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THEM SO WAS A PREMIUM ONLY IN
POURTANT.
THAT TO A NEW CEMETERY STATE
CEMETERY BE DEVELOPED THERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY.
OF WHICH BOTH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND ORANGE COUNTY WILL BENEFIT
FROM IT AND WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THAT EFFORT AND
HOPEFULLY THE THE COMMITTEE WILL
AS WELL.
RIGHT VERY GOOD ANY OF THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL UP.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY MADAM CHAIR --
I WANNA -- COMMAND -- THE AUTHOR --
MISS QUIRK SILVA -- FOR THIS
BILL -- I AM A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL.
MISS QUIRK SILVA AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING TOWARD THE GOAL OF A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY. FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
NOW -- THE CITY OF IRVINE.
STEPPED UP -- AS AS MISS QUIRK
SILVA SAID -- AND MANY YEARS AGO.
TO A PARTNERSHIP. TO CREATE THIS
VERY NECESSARY AND IMPORTANT
[inaudible]
VETERANS CEMETERY.
AND THE CITY MADE A COMMITMENT
TO THE STATE.
THE STATE HAS FOLLOWED THROUGH
ON ITS COMMITMENTS IS AS SPENT
MONEY -- ON THIS PROJECT --
PREPARING THE PLANS OF
SUBMITTING THE PLANS -- DEALING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHO
ULTIMATELY WILL HELP TO FUND.
THIS PROJECT AND SO I'M --
STRONG ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL.
AND AGAIN I WANT TO COMMEND --
MISS QUIRK SILVA FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS SUBJECT
[inaudible] EIGHT AND IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE HAVE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS SO WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM YET.
AS SOON AS WE DO WE WILL.
TAKE A VOTE ON THAT THE THE
RECOMMEND EIGHT EARNED
RECOMMENDATION OF COURSE IS DUE
PASSED -- TO APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO JUST
COULD I MAKE A QUICK GOES SO
JUST AS WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE WE ARE READY TO WORK
WITH THE STATE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS. TO SECURE YOUR
FUNDING FOR THE CENTER FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
MEMORIAL PARK.
AND WE ASK THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND FINING THIS FINAL
RESTING PLACE WE KNOW -- AND
NOTE THAT SIX YEARS HAVE GONE
PASSED IN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAVE KEPT ME.
ENGAGED IN THIS ISSUE ALTHOUGH
THERE HAVE BEEN VERY YEARS AND
OBSTACLES.
IS SOME OF THE AGING VETS THAT I
SEE A REGULARLY WHO SAY OH YEAH
YOU ARE THE ONE WORKING ON THAT
AND HURRY UP BECAUSE IF I CAN
FIND IT.
CAME RUNNING OUT OF TIME AND
JUST THIS LAST WEEK -- I WILL BE
BRINGING UP A VETERAN FOR OUR
VETERANS CELEBRATION WHO IS
NINETY THREE FROM FULLER TEN AND
SERVED US.
IN NOT ONLY WORLD WAR TWO BUT IT
AT MADE HIS WAY TO NORMANDY AND
THIS IS A FULLER TEN RESIDENT
WHO WILL BE ACKNOWLEDGING BUT WE
ARE RUNNING OUT OF TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A PLACE IN
ORANGE COUNTY FOR THEM TO REST
SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IF I MIGHT ADD.
I ALSO HAD WORKED ON THE CENTRAL
COAST CEMETERY WHICH TOOK US
TWENTY YEARS.
THIS IS NOW SIX YEARS.
AND I STAND WITH THE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERE THAT --
TIME IS IS IS MOVING QUICKLY AND
WE NEED TO REALLY MOVE ON THIS
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO DID
YOU HAVE A COMMENT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
SOME WOMAN QUIRK SILVA I JUST
WANNA PUBLICLY CONGRATULATE YOU
YOU'VE BEEN THE LEADER THIS
EFFORT FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
HONOR TO WORK WITH YOU -- I WAS
FRUSTRATED AT THE LAST EFFORT
WHERE WE HAD A A DEAL PUT
TOGETHER AND EVERYBODY WAS IN
SUPPORT AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
DC AND GET IT MOVED UP THE
PRIORITY CHAIN AND THEN.
YOU KNOW INITIATIVE WAS RUN AND
WE'RE BACK TO SQUARE ONE BUT THE
DELEGATIONS ALMOST UNANIMOUSLY
IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS IDEA -- THE OTHER THING
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
PRIVATELY THAT I WANT TO LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW ABOUT IS THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO FOR THE
WHOLE CEMETERY AT ONCE WANT
SOMETHING HAS BECOME VERY
POPULAR WITH THE VA ESPECIALLY
PLACES LIKE.
CORONADO WHERE THEY'RE CLOSED IS
COLUMBARIUM -- AND WE DON'T NEED
THAT MUCH LAND TO START A
COLUMBARIUM -- WE COULD
DESIGNATE TO SITE.
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF SEED MONEY
AND IT JUST STARTED WITH
CREMATION BETTER INFORMATION
SERVICES ONLY AND AS WE WORK ON
GETTING THE WHOLE CEMETERY BUILT
SO.
AGAIN ANYTHING I CAN DO TO HELP
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ON THIS SO WE CAN GET
THAT VETERANS CEMETERY BILL.
IT IS OF AND I DO APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE I DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE --
MY COLLEAGUES THIS ö
BIPARTISAN AND WE APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT NOT ONLY FROM A SUMMIT
MEMBER BRO BUT ALSO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAILY -- WORKED ON THIS
DILIGENTLY -- WHEN I WAS NOT UP
HERE FOR TWO YEARS AND HE REALLY
KEPT THE BALL ROLLING -- AND
THAT ALLOWED US TO GET MOVING
AGAIN WHEN I RETURN BUT IT WAS
REALLY HIS WORK WHILE I WAS NOT
HERE SO THANK YOU AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT HAND -- WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM NOW SO IF WE
COULD HAVE THE SECRETARY PLEASE
TAKE ROLE -- WHEN?
VOEPEL YOU'LL BOERNER HORVATH.
BRO.
DALY.
FRAZIER GLORIA.
MATHIS MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS SALAS.
AND THEN COULD I PLEASE WITHOUT
FOR AB [inaudible]
THREE SIX EIGHT I'LL.
AS A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS SECOND BY -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRO.
IRWIN YES IRWIN I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I BURNER HORRIDA.
BOERNER HORVATH AYE BRO.
BRO I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA [inaudible]
MATHIS MURATSUCHI PETRIE-NORRIS
SALAS.
SALAS AYE SEVEN ZERO AND THAT
FILLS OUT THANK YOU LAYS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
I CAN WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
PLEASE TO THE ROLL CALL AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER UNLESS YOU CAN
COME UP -- WHEN? FIVE WHEN I
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE BURNER HORIBA.
BURNER HORVATH EYEING BRO.
SO I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
SEVEN ZERO AND THE CAN OF
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
RAWNESS AT A WE'RE ANXIOUS TO
HEAR YOUR PRESENTATION ON A. B..
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
AND FIRST I'M WORKING WITH A
CONSULTANT COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
WE DID MAKE SOME AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS -- TO THE BILL.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX A SAYS
VETERANS WITH WORK EXPERIENCE
AND CYBERSECURITY TO EASILY
TRANSITION FROM SERVICE TO
EMPLOYMENT IN WHICH SECURITY
CLEARANCES AND BACKGROUND CHECKS
ARE REQUIRED.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
ONE MILLION VETERANS IN THE
UNITED STATES OF THAT ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION RESIDING
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS MORE THAN
ANY OTHER STATE IN THE NATION.
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES OFFER A VARIETY OF
WORK FORCE AND EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS TO ASSIST MILITARY
PERSONNEL TO OBTAIN DEGREES AND
REACH PATHWAYS TO PROFESSIONAL
CIVILIAN CAREERS.
IN MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
THE CYBERSECURITY CENTER AT
CALLOUS CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SAN BERNARDINO.
IS A VITAL ACADEMIC PROGRAM
WHICH ALLOWS FOR VETERANS
THROUGH SERVICE IN WHICH A
NATIONAL SECURITY CLEARANCE
STATUS WAS OBTAINED TO EASILY
UTILIZED THEIR WORK EXPERIENCE
IN THE PROGRAM.
AND THAT'S AN EXISTING PROGRAM
AT CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SAN BERNARDINO.
WHILE THE STATE PROVIDES
PROGRAMS FOR VETERANS TO ENTER
DIFFERENT PROFESSIONAL FILLS A
NICHE IT IS FOCUSED ON
CYBERSECURITY ARE OFTEN
OVERLOOKED.
HIRING CONSIDERATIONS AND
CYBERSECURITY INCLUDE LATE THE
SECURITY CLEARANCES DELAYS AND
ON BOARDING PROCESSES SEVERELY
IMPACTING THE SUFFICIENCY OF THE
CYBERSECURITY WORKFORCE.
FURTHER THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
UNIFORM HIRING SYSTEM IN PLACE
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
WITH THE STATE.
THAT ACCOUNTS FOR A VETERANS
PAST EXPERIENCE IN CYBERSECURITY
OR WHETHER HE OR SHE WANTS ARE
CURRENTLY HOLDS A NATIONAL
SECURITY CLEARANCE. TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERAN AFFAIRS TO COLLABORATE.
WITH STATE AGENCIES AND COLLEGES
TO ESTABLISH A VETERAN'S
PREFERENCE TO EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE FIELD
OF CYBER SECURITY THAT REQUIRE A
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
IN ADDITION BUILT THIS BILL
REQUIRES STATE AGENCIES HIRING
FOR CYBERSECURITY POSITIONS TO
ESTABLISH A UNIFORM HIRING
POLICY FOR VETERANS WHO HAVE
RECENTLY HOW.
A SECURITY CLEARANCE WITH ME
TODAY IS RICHARD VALDEZ A MARINE
VETERAN AND PURPLE HEART
RECIPIENT.
REPRESENTING DISABLED AMERICAN
VETERANS THE SPONSOR OF AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX HERE TO
TESTIFY AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
MADAM CHAIR AGAIN THANK YOU --
MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
THIS -- BEGAN IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE AND ROLLED INTO EARLY.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THIS WAS THE
TAIL END OF PRESIDENT JOHNSON'S
JOBS -- PROGRAM.
I WAS HIRED INTO THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY.
AND BECAUSE I WAS A VETERAN.
I WAS ON THE FLOOR OF A
CLASSIFIED BEAUTY CENTER WITHIN
TWO WEEKS AFTER ORIENTATION.
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THAT FACT.
AS A TIME WHEN ON MY CLEARANCES
ALSO -- GREW AND MY
OPPORTUNITIES GREW ALONG WITH
THAT -- TO THE EXTENT MY LAST
JOB WAS IN AUSTRALIA -- WORRY
WAS REQUIRED OF ME TO HAVE A AN
S. C. I. CLEARANCE -- FOR THE
THE BOTTOM LINE THE WAY I SEE IT
HERE IS THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS HAPPENING.
THERE'S THE PRESIDENTIAL
DIRECTIVE WITH REGARDS TO THE
OUT CYBERSECURITY WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT A FOR THE NATION
WHICH HAS A HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND SHORT OF HAVING -- THE
TRAINED PERSONNEL THEY NEED FOR
THAT SO THERE'S A STRONG
EMPHASIS THERE.
AND PART OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE IN THAT -- THAT DIRECTIVE
LEANS TOWARDS VETERANS.
DISABLED VETERANS AND VETERANS
IN GENERAL THOSE TRANSITIONING.
THAT THAT'S ALREADY RESOURCE
AVAILABLE TO US.
AS I'VE LEARNED -- THROUGH THE
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY STAMINA
DINO I ASKED ONE QUESTION HOW
MANY VETERANS DO YOU HAVE IN
YOUR CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM.
AND THURSDAY -- WORK UNAWARE AND
FINALLY THEY FIND OUT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ANY.
BUT WE HAVE PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
THE SERVICE WITH THAT TRAINING.
WE HAVE THOSE COMING OUT OF THE
SERVICE WITH THE DESIRE TO MOVE
INTO THAT -- CAREER FIELD BUT IN
REALITY.
AS I ASKED AROUND THERE REALLY
ISN'T ANY -- MOTION ON THE PART
OF ALL OF THE STATE OF HEART OF
CAL THAT. TO WHAT TO ACTUALLY
INFORM OUR VETERANS OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
AND SO THAT'S WHEN I STARTED
ASKING MORE QUESTIONS BECAME
FAMILIAR WITH -- WITH PROFESSOR
KEITH CLEMENT AT FRESNO STATE
PROFESSOR TONY -- COLSON SALMON
DINO US STATE UNIVERSITY CALVET.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SALMON TO DO YOU KNOW AND AND
FROM THAT HI -- BEGAN ASKING THE
QUESTIONS.
THAT IS.
PART OF WHY THIS BILL CAME ABOUT.
TO BE ABLE TO INITIATE A PROGRAM
WITHIN THE STATE TO STARTED DOWN
A FINE THOSE THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AND PUT THEM TOGETHER IN A
PATHWAY A PIPELINE TO EITHER --
A DEGREE CERTIFICATED PROGRAM
AND OR DIRECTLY INTO A JOB
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE REQUISITE
SKILLS AND ABILITY.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW VETERANS ARE
MISSION ORIENTED WILL GET THE
JOB DONE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON CHAIRWOMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SET THREE BUT THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
HAVE REPRESENT AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OF
SEVENTY SIX OUR CLIENT SUPPORTS
ALL NEW IN IT AND INNOVATIVE
WAYS TO CREATE JOBS FOR THE
VETERANS OF CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY IS A GROWING FIELD.
BUT THE DEMAND FOR EMPLOYMENT
THIS IS A GREAT WAY TO ATTRACT
AND KEEP VETERANS IN THE STATE
HELP TRANSITIONING VETERANS.
AND A GREAT POPULATION TO TARGET
FOR THESE JOBS HAS THERE AND
TRAINED TO IMPROVISE ADAPT AND
OVERCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ALSO A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS BILL IS A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SO
I WOULD START OFF BY THANKING MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
LIFE AFTER THE MILITARY CAN POSE
MANY CHALLENGES TO VETERANS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS. FOR SOME
RETURNING TO CIVILIAN LIFE MAY
FEEL LIKE ANOTHER BATTLE THAT
POSES A VARIETY OF CHALLENGES.
THAT WAS NOT ONLY BE FOUGHT BUT
ALSO UNDERSTOOD AND ACCEPTED IN
ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFULLY
OVERCOME.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL OF OUR
VETERANS HAVE THE ADEQUATE
SUPPORT SYSTEM NEEDED TO
TRANSITION INTO THE WORKFORCE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP OUR VETERANS
WHO HAVE WORK EXPERIENCE IN THE
CYBER SECURITY FIELD TO EASILY
TRANSITION INTO EMPLOYMENT.
WE MUST PROVIDE THESE RESOURCES
TO THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE
SERVEDOUR COUNTRY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
PERFECT TIMING TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
YEAH.
AFTERNOON LORRAINE PLOTS --
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA.
I AM VETS AND SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
I'M ALSO THE NEWEST THE NATIONAL
VICE CHAIR OF LEGISLATION -- WE
SUPPORT THIS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
AT AND HE BUT IN OPPOSITION
COMMENTS FROM THE PANEL
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL
SO.
I VOTE FOR THIS BILL IN A HEART
BEAT BECAUSE IT'S A GREAT BILL.
I HAVE TWO THINGS THAT YOU MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER ADDING ON TO IT
TO MAKE IT BETTER [inaudible]
OR NOT.
SO.
ON THE SECURITY CLEARANCES YOU
MAY WANT TO DO AN AMENDMENT
SAYING.
CONFIDENTIAL AND ABOVE CLEARANCE
BECAUSE MILITARY CLEARANCES GO
CONFIDENTIAL SECRET TOP SECRET.
BUT THERE'S OTHER.
CLEARANCES WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
OKAY SO JUST YOU MAY WANT TO
TIGHTEN IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
NOW THERE MAY BE ONE THING YOU
WANT TO LOOSEN UP A LITTLE BIT
HERE ON THIS BILL.
AND THAT'S CYBERSECURITY YOU MAY
WANT TO SIMPLY SAY INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN
THERE'S AN UNKNOWN FACTOR HERE.
WE DON'T KNOW [inaudible]
WHAT?
THESE VETERANS AND ACTIVE DUTY.
ARE INVOLVED IN.
THEY MAY BE DOING IN A NEW --
PATHWAY.
OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW.
SO YOU MAY WANT TO BROADEN THAT
DEFINITION SIMPLY TO TAKE IN
SPECIALLY IN THE FUTURE AS
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES.
WHAT [inaudible]
THEY'RE DOING.
AND THAT'S IT NO THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THOSE -- QUESTIONS IN
THOSE ARE AREAS THAT WILL
DEFINITELY LOOK INTO ROGER THAT.
RIGHT TO AND SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO AND A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
AND THE MOTION IS -- DO PASSED
TO PRIVACY -- SO I I THINK THAT --
AND THAT COMMITTEE WILL BE
DIGGING A LITTLE DEEPER INTO
YOUR BILL BUT A GREAT IDEA WE
ARE PROBABLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
POSITION SHORT.
AND CYBERSECURITY AND IT'S A
PERFECT -- FIT TO HAVE VETERANS
TRAINED IN THAT AREA WITH THE
BACKGROUND THEY GET IN THE
MILITARY.
SO ON THAT CAN YOU PLEASE TO THE
ROLE.
TECH -- WHEN I -- WHEN I VOEPEL?
VOEPEL I WERNER **** BATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I THROW.
BRO I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
MATHIS MURATSUCHI PETRIE-NORRIS
SALAS.
SALAS AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
MOVE EVERYTHING THE CHAIRMAN HAS.
ABSOLUTELY ALL RIGHTS -- SHALL I
GET STARTED YES MA'AM MY SHARE --
GOOD AFTERNOON YOU ALL KNOW THE
HISTORY OF THE AUDIT I REQUEST
ON THE LEASHES LEASES AND OTHER
USES OF REAL PROPERTY AT THE
CALIFORNIA VETERANS HOMES AND
THE FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT CAME OUT IN THAT AUDIT.
THIS BILL CODIFIES A THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVING
THESE TERMS AND ENSURING THE USE
OF THE PROPERTY PROVIDE A
BENEFIT TO RESIDENTS OF THE
HOMES THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE PURPOSE.
IS THERE ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN A
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN UNIFORM
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL AND THE VIETNAM
VETERANS OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA
STATE.
COUNSEL ALL IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO FORTY IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THE STATE OPERATE THESE HOMES IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
VETERANS OF ALSO PROTECTING THE
VIABILITY.
OF THE HOMES IN UP HOLDING THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST REGARDING THE
CARE OF THOSE MEN AND WOMEN.
OF OUR REALLY SERVE THIS COUNTRY
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER DEDICATION
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BILL AUTHOR HI
MY NAME IS A WARRANT.
I AM FROM THE ON FIELD VETERANS
SO.
I CAME HERE TODAY I LIKE TO
SUPPORT IT.
AS A PRESIDENT OF THE THE
VETERANS HOMES ASSOCIATION.
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT.
TRYING TO GET STARTED THERE AT
THE HOME.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT I SHALL
BRING FOR THE ALLIED COUNCIL SO
THAT BY THE TIME THE GUESTS OF
NEXT COMMITTEE.
I PLEASE ALLY COUNCIL ALSO WOULD
SUPPORT IT.
THERE ARE TWO AREAS WHICH A I
HOPE TO TALK TO YOUR STAFF AND
KNEW ABOUT. ONE MIGHT BE TO ADD
SOME MORE NUTS AND BOLTS. TO
HAVE OUR PROPERLY MIGHT WORK --
UMASS BUILD BACK TWENTY THIRTEEN
STARTED TO DO THIS AND THEY GOT
SIDETRACKED WHEN GOT HIJACKED.
ALSO AS A MEMBER IN A VETERAN.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE.
ABILITY FOR THE AMERICAN
VETERANS TO HAVE A SAY IN SOME
OF THE PROCESSES
I THINK THAT -- GOING BACK TO
THE FIRST ONE IF IF THE VETERANS
HAD KNOWN ABOUT THE ZIP LINE --
WITH ALL THEIR BAD BACKS THEY
WOULD NEVER OF THOUGHT THAT WAS
A GOOD IDEA HOME.
SO -- SO I THINK THERE'S REAL
VALUE HAVING -- THE VETERANS
TALK ABOUT WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST.
OF THE VETERANS.
AND SO IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO STRENGTHEN THE BILL -- AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU COMING.
OUT OF THE LITTLE HOOVER AND THE
OTHER HEARINGS TO FOLLOW THROUGH
ON THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ALEX TORE AS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT LIKE TO THANK.
THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK ON THIS --
LOOK FORWARD TO CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE AUDIT SOME THERE'S
ALSO THE ODD IN THE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
THERE WOULD THERE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER CHAIR I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION BUT I WOULD DO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE BILL THANK
YOU.
THIS IS ALICE.
THANK YOU MISTER I JUST WANTED
TO THANK ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN
FOR THE TESTIMONY THAT WE HAD WE
HAD A HEARING A JOINT HEARING.
ON THESE ISSUES AND I THINK WE
LEARNED A LOT AND YOU'VE
INCORPORATED A LOT OF WHAT THE
AUDITOR HAD INTO -- THE
LEGISLATION I KNOW WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS AND APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT OFF
HER RIGHT.
I THINK SO.
YEAH MANDATE THAT PLAN IN CHAIR
WHICH LED CLOTHES -- JUST ASK --
FOR BUT PLEASE ROGER THAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
AND SECOND FROM [inaudible]
SALAS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS MEMBER I'M
DON'T GET TO DO THIS VERY OFTEN
[inaudible]
PLEASE VOTE.
WE'LL TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO HAVE TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI -- WHEN
I VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE BURNER?
BOERNER HORVATH AYE BRO.
BRO I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA MATHIS
MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS SALAS SALAS AYE
[inaudible]
SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
THEN.
A. B. SIX NINETY FOUR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE VETERANS HOUSING AND
HOMELESS -- PREVENTION BOND ACT
OF TWENTY NINETEEN THE AN AXE
THE THE H. H. P. TO AUTHORIZE
THE ISSUANCE OF BONDS PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION.
OF AFFORDABLE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING WITH SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
FOR VETERANS OVER FOUR ROUNDS OF
FUNDING V. H. H. P. HAS PROVIDED
OVER TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED HOUSING
UNITS FOR VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THERE IS NOW ABOUT -- TWO
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
LEFT FOR VH H. P. AT A RATE OF
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION PER ROUND
THAT FUNDING WILL RUN OUT IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO GET A BOND
ON THE TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT THE
BILL WILL HAVE TO PASS THIS YEAR
OR WITH AN URGENCY CLAUSE.
NEXT YEAR THEY'RE AN ESTIMATED
TWELVE THOUSAND HOMELESS
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND EVEN MORE STRUGGLING WITH
HOUSING AND SECURITY A. B. SIX
NINE FOUR WILL ASSIST VETERANS
WHO ARE HOMELESS.
OR WHO NEED AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING TO SECURE HOUSING FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IS THERE ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER VICE CHAIR NUMBERS --
ALEX TOWARDS ONCE AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES VERY QUICKLY WAS
SATURDAY AGAIN THE PROPORTION OF
HOMELESS VETERANS THAT RESIDE IN
CALIFORNIA I WOULD SIMPLY --
URGENT AYE VOTE AND ARGUE THIS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
DO WE NEED A SECOND ON THE
MOTION [inaudible]
A SECOND.
IS THERE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
YES SIR.
SOME MEMBER IRWIN SO I'M A
GENERAL CONTRACTOR BUILD HOMES
ALL MY LIFE.
WHAT IS THE -- EXPENDITURE PLAN
IN PLACE FOR THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WE WE HAVEN'T SO.
WHAT WE WILL HAVE THAT BEFORE WE
GO TO APPROPRIATIONS?
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
PLAN AND AND THIS IS EITHER WE
WERE LOW.
AS WE WHEN WE SEE THE NUMBER
WILL LOOK AT EITHER THE TWENTY
TWENTY VALID OR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BALLOT AND AS YOU
KNOW THE VHP HAS BEEN.
A VERY SUCCESSFUL AN
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND WE ASSUME
THAT THE NEED WILL CONTINUE BUT
THOSE THOSE NUMBERS WERE STILL
WORKING THROUGH.
AND SOMEHOW AND AGAIN THIS IS
ABSOLUTE -- VALID IN THE NEED.
OF RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND HOMES THAT
NEED TO BE BUILT BECAUSE OF THE
WILDFIRES.
IN A REALLY DOES OVERSUBSCRIBED
THE TALENT.
POOL THAT WE HAVE SOMEHOW WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO INCENTIVIZE
OUR YOUNGER GENERATIONS TO COME
IN AND BE PART OF THIS PROCESS.
INSTEAD OF BEING MILLENNIALS AND
DOING THE THE TECHIE THING.
WE ACTUALLY CRAFTS PEOPLE TO TO
BE ABLE TO TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
AND I HOPE WE CAN FIND THAT.
THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT MY ROLE GOING
FORWARD BECAUSE LIKE I SAY WE'RE
OVER SUBSCRIBE NOW AND WE'RE
GLAD PUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OUT THERE.
WE DON'T HAVE THE WORK FORCE.
WE'RE DOING THESE PEOPLE A
DISSERVICE YOU KNOW SO I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE GET
BUILT AS A PRIORITY?
ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND DALY
[inaudible]
WILL.
THE CHAIR PLEASE CLOSE. TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE UP.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- WHEN I -- WHEN
I VOEPEL?
VOEPEL I A BURNER HORRIDA --
**** BATH AYE BRO.
BRO I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS MURATSUCHI
PETRIE-NORRIS SALAS.
SALAS AYE. EIGHT ZERO WE'VE.
WE'VE MOVED A CONSENT CALENDAR
OF WE ARE GOING TO GIVE THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF FIVE MINUTES
TO COME DOWN HERE AND VOTE AND
IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE
SECRETARY TO GO THROUGH THE
BILL'S AGAIN.
YEAH YOU'RE GONNA Là AB TWO
FOUR TO FORTY IRWIN [inaudible]
I AB. THREE SIX THREE THIRTY
THREE SIXTY QUIRK SILVA.
YEAH.
I ONE SIX NINE FOUR THE NOT THAT.%
ONE THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX RAMOS
[inaudible]
REMEMBER.
MR ROSE.
OKAY LIMITS ARE GLORIA THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
GLORIA.
I THINK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT RIGHT
.
WITH THAT SAID [inaudible]
THEY ALSO [inaudible]
THE PROBLEM
-- THAT.
YEAH HEY AB TWO FORTY IRWIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
OKAY.
AB THREE SIX EIGHT PARKS OVER
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS I AB SIX NINE FOUR
IRWIN PETRIE-NORRIS.
WHICH ONE SIX NINE FOUR
PETRIE-NORRIS I THEN AB ONE
THREE SEVEN SIX THREE MOST
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I AN FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS I
OUR OKAY AB.
TWO FORTY MATHIS.
MATHIS I AB THREE SIX EIGHT
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS I ABC SIX NINE FOUR
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO.
AB ONE THREE SEVEN SIX MATHIS.
MATHIS I IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MATHIS I
YEAH.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
THERE'S LOTS OF TO BETTER HER
SISTER